we're gonna get started today uh today
this is the orientation for data science
uh for biomedical data
um so for some of you that have already
participated in the orientation that
happened last week uh this introduction
will be a little bit of review for you
but for those of you that were not
able to come to that orientation this
will be fresh information
so first off i want to thank lsu biomed
as well as lvrn for funding these
training modules available biomed is
under lsu it's a group of cores and it
stands for the division of biotechnology
and molecular medicine that's the
biomed down here gene lab is one of the
cores within biomed and i'll talk a
little bit more about that at the end of
the
lecture here
and then lbrn is louisiana biomedical
research network
which is a consortium of universities
that work together
to further louisiana's research
potential as through collaboration and
communication but um that aside let's go
ahead and get started as to uh the
information that you guys are here for
today
so
a little bit of overview about what
these training models are so these
training modules are designed to be
completely asynchronous and that is
because many of us have very big busy
schedules right so the opportunities
available here for you to uh jump in and
jump out around your schedule and work
with on your time timelines
really should benefit you here
additionally
you're not in this alone so the purpose
of these programs is to help guide you
through the information and provide you
with interactions similar to how you
would with say a professor or an expert
in the field that would be teaching a
similar course so um for these training
models you'll have access to a variety
of mentors that will uh interact with
you both through lectures as well as be
accessible through online chat
which has a variety of options for you
to reach out to them and email of course
and
once you have gone through the program
once you've reached the completion of
the program
you will receive a certificate so that
you can prove that you completed this
training module and have a better
understanding of data science now
depending on what institution you come
from that certificate will look a little
different so if you come from lsu
your certificate will be customized to
lsu and be signed by dr gus casoulis
if you come from lbrn your certificate
will also be customized but it will be
signed by
the lbrns bioinformatics core
lead chris taylor
if you are not part of lsu or lbrn your
certificate will be
similar to a standardized certificate
that you would receive if you completed
the program independently
so that being said there are three main
things that you're going to utilize
while you go through these programs that
are going to help you through the lesson
plans or you'll interact with uh
frequently the biggest one you're going
to interact with frequently is the
omixlogic portal i'm going to show you
how to register for that in a little bit
um the mxlogic portal is essentially the
location of the website you're going to
go to and access all of your lesson
plans where you're going to see your
syllabus for the program as well as
access a variety of mentor interaction
options
the next thing that you're going to
interact with fairly frequently is the
tbio platform so the tbio platform is
designed to allow you to input
uh bioinformatics acquired data
uh and then run it through a various
pipeline of analyses so that you can go
through the normal process that a
bioinformatician would to analyze the
different data except this is a much
easier for those that don't have the
expertise
to perform the analyses uh through their
own coding
however you're not just going to be
using this platform you are going to
learn how to code to some extent
this program in particular is going to
involve much more coding than the other
two that are being offered uh this
semester so
you're going to be doing this partially
because you guys are a coding course you
will have some uh work with the coding
playground
and so the coding playground is
essentially a virtual or online
playground or a coding environment so
that you can practice your coding online
without having to establish a coding
environment on your computer um
now because you guys are coding uh based
training module you'll likely also have
to set up a coding environment on your
own computer but this as you learn will
be available to you so you don't have to
go through that process right away
so this is an intermediate-based
difficulty course this basically means
that it's targeted towards individuals
that have an understanding of both
biological and data science concepts
as well as some experience with
statistics and some experience with
coding
you don't have to be experts on any of
these things but the expectation is that
you are able to understand some of the
information given to you from the get-go
so this there are two other difficulty
level offered training programs this
semester which we'll be talking about
transcriptomics tomorrow if you're still
interested
and we were talking about uh
introduction to bioinformatics yesterday
and that recording will be available
online
so what exactly is this training module
so this training module the orientation
is obviously today but you have access
available to you already if you've
registered
this training module is designed to help
you analyze bioinformatic data that's
from everything from data wrangling all
the way through visualizing your data
many of us have seen visualized
bioinformatic data if you work in
biomedical field
but this course is designed this
training model is designed to help you
go through uh the actual steps and
understand the analyses that are going
on behind the data visualization because
there's a lot of steps to get to that
visualization
point
some of the concepts you're going to
cover
um is statistical concepts uh as their
and their applications to biological
data
machine learning and deep learning
python and our coding as well as coding
challenges that you can start to
understand how to do the coding yourself
as well as how data sharing now you're
also going to have a variety of ways to
learn this it's hands-on exercises
there's tutorials uh there's lessons
there's the mentor guided lectures
there's plenty of learning opportunities
here
that will help lead you through this
process
and it's not just going to be
conceptual applications this training
module is targeted to also be able to
practically apply this information in
your research world in your clinical
world and the variety of other
applications that data science finds
itself in
and like i said you're going to be able
to practice this as you go so you're not
going to be stuck just learning the
concepts
so i'm not going to go through all the
details of the lecture or all the
syllabus but these are uh here's your
syllabus these are the finalized dates
uh later on ilia will go into more
detail about that
additionally there are other resources
available to you especially if you're
coming from lsu or lbrn um like i
mentioned the very beginning there's lsu
gene lab and lsu team lab is available
to everyone within the lsu network or
the lbrn network
basically what lsu genelab is designed
for us to design is to provide
consulting as well as a variety of
experimental services which range from
next generation sequencing all the way
to automated cell counting i listed a
few of those services here
this is not their full list
but this
laboratory and this service laboratory
is available to anyone within those
networks and can very much help your
research if you're not familiar with one
of these techniques
additionally lbrn like i mentioned chris
taylor
is associated here with the
bioinformatics biostatistics and
computational biology core
this core is basically designed to
provide consulting mentorship and
training uh
focused in bioinformatics and data
science fields and how they're applied
to biological data now this is targeted
towards faculty and pi so keep that in
mind
if you reach out to them
this program is also designed to create
a project at the end now i did want to
give this information to individuals
that every year lbrn holds a conference
focused on computational biology and
bioinformatics this is usually around
april or springtime um so once you
complete the project in this training
module you'll have the opportunity to
present that project at this particular
conference or any conference of your
your choosing if you're interested in
that
additionally uh some new information i
received today is that there is also a
master's program focused on
bioinformatics available at the lsu
health center in new orleans
so if you're interested you can look
that up uh yourself if you want to
continue your your knowledge into the
bioinformatic field
and finally if you're a faculty member
or a pi another institution and you're
interested in having these programs or
training models offered at your
institution you can contact ilya brodsky
who is the ceo of pine biotech who is
offering these training models at illya
pinebio
for more information
so i'm going to hold here before i show
you how to register
but i'll take any questions if anyone
has any questions about this process
itself
if not we're going to move on to the
registration
no sir
okay so if we don't have any questions
i'm gonna go ahead and switch screens
here
i'm gonna show you how to register on
the omixlogic portal
so for those of you that have not done
this already if you're interested in
this training module you have to
register on omxlogic before we can
add you to the course the training model
so to do so you're going to go to
learn.omicslogic.com
when you come to this page
you will be able to see
clearly in the front how to register for
free
and they put that link in the chat
i will also mention before i go through
this that there is another website i'll
put the link in the chat that will go
through all the other training programs
and training modules that are offered at
lsu or through the lsu biomed and lbrn
network this semester so you can go that
link if you're interested in the other
training modules but like i said
go to learn.mxlogic.com to register for
any of these training models the way to
do so is to click register for free down
here
and once it loads up you'll see on the
right hand side a sign in or sign up
section
all you have to do once you get to this
section if you already have an account
you can sign in here if you don't
already have an account there will be a
small button you'll have to click to
expand the information
to allow you to register for
learn.mxlogic.com
great so here so if you already have an
account you'll sign in here uh if you
don't click on create an account right
here this box will expand for you and
give you and ask you a few a little bit
more information like your name the
institution that you're with et cetera
et cetera but since i already have an
account i'm going to go ahead and log in
so i can show you a brief introduction
of the profile on mxlogic and how to
access the information that you'll need
to access for this training
so when you log in you'll open up to
this page i recommend going to your
profile by clicking on right here
welcome back your email will be listed
and it'll take you to your profile
once you're added to the training module
you'll have two ways to access the
syllabus easily from your profile the
first one would be come down here and
click on the data science badge
the other way to do so would be go over
here to the programs tab at the top of
your profile page
click on that
and once this loads you're going to go
to biomed data science for biomedical
data
before i jump there i do want to show
you how to access some other things here
on your profile page
one that you'll use frequently is your
courses so once you have started a
asynchronous course you're going to be
able to find it under the course tabs to
continue it because again this is on
your schedule and then you might not
always be able to complete a lesson in
one sitting but what you can do is come
to the courses tab and find whatever
courses you have started and easily
access them later on
you'll also be able to access any
certificates you receive
and i can show you what one of these
looks like now
and once this loads
so this is what your certificate of
completion will look like and like i
said depending on the institution you
come from it'll be more customized and
it'll be signed by a different
individual but if you're coming from an
outside institution it will look very
similar to this and it will be signed by
an individual associated with pine
biotech
so if i go back here i'm going to show
you the syllabus page very briefly
under the programs tab like i said you
can go to your syllabus at any time
or the program page where you'll find
your syllabus
so here's your program page if you have
not registered already you will not have
this pop up here this is because i've
already been registered if you haven't
already registered if you go to this
page this link you'll be able to scroll
down and you'll be able to find pricing
uh in this area about how to access the
program
but since you're most of you should
already be registered
you'll be able to scroll down and you'll
find today's the first lesson so here's
your find the syllabus information and
also the information for each individual
lesson today being october 7th you can
see this is the topics that are going to
be covered today and here are the
associated resources that you should uh
go through
after this lesson
now once you complete everything with
this lesson you'll be able to click
complete complete lesson here
and once you have done that for every
single uh lesson in the program you'll
receive your certificate
okay so that being said that's all i'm
going to cover today i'm going to go
ahead and hand off
to ilia with pine biotech and he'll go
over some more details about the
training program